hey everyone thank you for coming on
this like I think it's like a perfect
slot for this conference it's the first
day so I'm not too hungover it's in the
afternoon so I'd have like my maximum
caffeine intake and I'm just gonna be
coasting for the rest of the day so I
feel pretty good about things so my name
is Jimmy Bogart you could follow me on
twitter at JB guard we're the warning
you may want to UM you know you may want
to mute untappd if you follow me you'll
see quite a few those tweets coming up
you can find me at github conveniently
also I'd github.com /j Bogart and that's
also where you find the presentation
here as well as any kind of code and
things like that you can find their
github I blog about this subject as well
as a lot of others on my website at
Jimmy Bogart calm and for my day job
actually work for a company called head
spring out of Austin Texas it was a very
long ride on my horse on the way here so
he's very tired and for my day job I do
consulting for companies where I build
custom complex systems so a lot of
things we'll be talking about it really
just let a lessons learned from
implementing this kind of architecture
over the past I don't know six or seven
years or so and that's the mother junk
about me I do a lot of open source stuff
and I think I get an award for doing
that I don't really know why I get it
but I don't say no I get free stuff so
hooray free stuff I've enjoyed my time
in Australia so far there's a few things
that I would improve though I have yet
to have a single Tim Tam slam which I
think I need to fix that pretty soon and
also there's no Starbucks what's come on
guys yeah get Jake yeah I mean get your
coffee stuff together please all right
so let's let's talk a little bit about
vertical slice architecture so I've been
a few talks in this area over the years
it's really talking about one of our
journey from the previous kinds of
systems we were working with and this
kind of architecture so this talk is
really about looking at us doing this
kind of architecture for the past six or
seven years and talking about some of
the lessons learned and patterns we've
seen while working in this kind of
architecture so first I want to do a
little bit of a history lesson ooh let
me switch over here
there we go a little bit of a history
lesson this is of course the Battle of
Waterloo so a very large part of my
career I was actually Napoleon and which
psy marched all the way to Russia lost
almost all my army came all the way back
and then was defeated and then for the
rest of my career I was the other guy
the Duke of Wellington I think I don't
know we don't really get much history
outside of Texas like we were a country
you know so anyway so a little bit of a
history lesson that led us up to the
vertical slice architecture that we're
doing today and it really all started
with us doing a lot of traditional
interior style architectures and for the
most most of my career this was kind of
the way to build systems into build
applications so a lot of the a lot of
the documentation from Microsoft when
they were first getting started with net
really recommended to build applications
and architectures like this where I have
a very kind of very segmented heavily
layered kind of architecture where I
have a user interface layer they can
only talk to the business logic layer
the business logic layer is supposed to
be isolated so it doesn't really do
anything else it only has abstraction x'
it talks to not any real dependencies
and of course we have to have the data
access layer and the database we
improved upon this model of course with
domain different designs so now we had a
domain layer and repository but is
basically a similar kind of traditional
inter architecture for most of my career
so and these kind of architectures a lot
of the code we had was then organized by
those individual layers so if I had
something in my system that was dealing
with like a person or order or an
invoice or something like that we'd have
different objects related to the
different things that you would want to
do with that specific object so we'd
have things like a person object of
course and the person object contained
the data and probably not any behavior
but mostly just data associated with
that object for the user interface part
we'd have the person controller so that
was where the main web request came in
for you to to interact with this thing
for all the business logic of course we
don't want to put that in the user
interface layer so we moved all the
business logic into service classes and
inevitably those service classes were
then named
after the main entity or object they
were related to so for this that meant
we had a person service that service had
to do some kind of data access where
there's queries to go ahead and build
out a list of people or something like
that or to get individual parts so that
we had to put that inside of a person
repository and so we had to be very
strict about the kinds of logic we put
in each of these places but one of the
things we found was that these became
sort of dumping grounds for all the
kinds of logic in her system
so anything dealing with a person in
terms of business logic all got dumped
into that service class anything dealing
with data access again got dumped in the
person repository so those classes and
types grew and grew and grew over time
until at one point we looked back and
said I don't think I don't think we're
doing this right because we keep going
down this later architecture all it's
doing is giving its larger and larger
objects that just makes merging harder
and harder and harder because more than
one person would be editing the service
class and we check in and then someone
would change this part in this part we
get this conflict of like oh we're just
we're all thrashing over these very
common objects and these very common
layers whenever I needed to change the
system I noticed I knew I was jumping
around the codebase quite a lot in
Evernote codebase we would organize all
these objects by layer
so we'd have folders for each of the
kinds of layers in our systems we had a
folder for controllers a folder for
services a folder for repositories we
agent this is a simplified view we had a
vegetable-based architecture I think you
know what I'm talking about if you buy
it you start to cry
we certainly cried a lot with the the
onion based architecture we had for so
long and each of these folders was
actually pulled out in two separate
projects so the project structure became
pretty complicated as well so when we
ever we wanted to make a change to this
system we had to go to all these
different locations to just do something
like add a different new field to the
screen so we wanted to add a new field
well of course we had to go to the
controllers to be able to say this new
object needs to have this new set of
properties there we needed to change any
kind of services or handlers associated
with it so way to go to that folder as
well we had to change how that
information was displayed in
screen so we had to change the view
models associated with it and the view
models folder and then finally we had of
course go to the views folder to
actually change how the things were
displayed so we found ourselves jumping
around a whole lot and made it really
difficult to understand when I made a
change all the different things that I
need to all the different things I need
a touch because everything was spread
out according to the kind of thing it
was as opposed to bringing everything
together when it needed to change
together so part of this project we
threw out all those notions of any kind
of layered architecture and move towards
what I called vertical slices I wish I
had a more clever name than this so
maybe afterwards someone can like
trademark something better than this but
this is about the best thing I can come
up with is dealing with code in vertical
slices and then when we look at this is
instead of thinking about all of our all
of our code and the kind buckets so it's
saying all these service kind of code
belongs in a service all the repository
kind of code belongs in a repository and
instead of looking at what I need to
make a change to the system everything I
need a touch in order to make that
change why don't we put all that code in
one spot so that was the very first
thing we did when we built this kind of
vertical slice architecture we looked at
I'm making a new change of the system
and we literally wrote it on the
whiteboard that says I have to change
this class I have to name this task in
this class how can I take all that code
that is it is very much related to each
other and pull it all together into one
spot so what that when I have to reason
about a feature or understand how the
system behaves for specific action or
tasks the user is performing I can just
go to one spot to see all the code
related to that change now the way we
did this was a lot of refactoring so
thankfully we all had resharper licenses
because Visual Studio at the time didn't
have anything but I guess you can just
use that today JetBrains is a sponsoring
so I think you can say you can use
Visual Studio right yeah so I moved all
the code related to a change as close
together as possible sometimes in the
exact same file I went to those original
layer classes
I have something like a some kind of
noun based service and that service had
different methods for the different
kinds of things you would do with that
for that domain object and I moved all
those individual methods into individual
classes for each of the kinds of things
it would do so if I could approve reject
or flag an invoice instead of having one
class that had every single kind of
thing you'd do with that thing in one
single file
I moved each of the different operations
that would never be executed with each
other into their own individual classes
so when I changed for example the
approve function I don't have to worry
about the side effects with rejecting or
flagging an invoice because all the code
related to that kind of operation was
separated out from all the different
other different pieces now this did
result in like way more classes in my
system so if you like to have fewer
classes then this is definitely not the
architecture for you if you like to have
things very much organized and separate
from each other so you don't to worry
about anything messing with each other
then this is what we found work really
well for us so this is our first step
was just taking all of those individual
methods and moving them to separate
classes then we looked at each class and
said you know what these all look
similar but not quite the same they look
like they're just performing one action
so they're just doing an approval
they're doing a rejection or doing a
flagging and there's some kind of like
input to the thing it does the work and
then there's some kind of output so we
started explicitly modeling our classes
to represent that kind of abstraction so
instead of representing our abstractions
in terms of like services and
repositories and said we had a request
to do something then the work itself and
then finally whatever the output of that
thing was so looked something like this
everything and our system had some kind
of input then some kind of handler that
would handle that request to do the work
and then sometimes that work to be done
it would have some kind of output so
over the course of like 2 or 3 years I
did this pattern
several projects and I got to the point
where I said just copying the same code
over and over again and even though I do
a lot of open-source I'm really I don't
really enjoy doing it it's not that fun
to get all these Stack Overflow
questions and people complaining about
your stuff so I eventually said okay
fine I'll create an open source library
that just I don't have to keep copying
this code over and over again and so I
pulled that code out to represented this
kind of pattern of requests handlers and
responses into a full-fledged library
and this library is called mediator or
mediate are I don't know how to
pronounce it right even though I named
the thing I should probably get that
sorted out now of course have you
noticed the name it was I made it around
the time signal art came out and I'm not
that clever with names so that's why
it's called mediate are and it's also
very Google a ball so that's good I
always want that anyway so what I did
was I took all those disparate request
objects that I just each time made up on
my own and said let's just represent
those requests as a first-class citizen
in our application and so each request
is now represented by some class that
implements this interface I request of T
now that T actually represents the
response type so every request is
inherently coupled to the response that
it will produce and in the middle from
ticket from that request type to the
response type is the magic handler that
just is like the stupidest interface
possible which is take a request and
return a response very exciting stuff
right of course we're all a sync a wheat
stuff right so now instead of just
returning T I have to return tasks of T
unfortunately it's everywhere right
everything we have to do is task
oriented so anyway now it has a task of
T as its return just in case I need to
do async stuff so everything in my
system now revolves around these
individual requests they handler to do
the work and then finally whatever
response comes out the other side now
registering all my handlers is pretty
straightforward just this is a speii net
core dependency injection junk so I try
to make it as easy as possible to add
this to my system
so down there you could have there's a
line that says services dot add mediator
and you tell we're to look for your
handlers and knows how to register all
of them so I just want to make it as
easy as possible to add this to my
applications so everything in my system
was revolved around these requests but
it got a little bit more subtle than
that
and they types a request that have my
system and I found that most of my
systems actually all of them had
different kinds of requests I typically
build web applications whether it's
server-side web applications NBC's kind
of traditional server-side rendering NBC
or even like single page applications or
just pure web api's all those
applications basically revolve around
gets and posts I know there are more
exotic like HTTP methods than post but
I'd say 99% of the time the systems I
build either get information outs or I'm
trying to change something and so those
can be represented as requests to either
get data in the form of a query or to
change something in the form of a post
so my gets then represented queries and
those queries were kind of requests
where the request was a query there'd be
some kind of handler to do whatever work
was necessary and finally that would
return the response and that response
was the data that you were interested in
the post represented the commands that
is I want to change something in the
system and then these also had a similar
kind of structure and that the commands
now were the requests that have some
kind of handler to handle that request
seduced to change some information and
then finally of course we have that
response know one of the big things I
wanted to make sure when I did this was
to encapsulate everything necessary to
perform that action that as the handlers
themselves wanted to have everything
that it needed to do to be represented
inside of those query and command
objects so I had this very simplified
view of the world and I like simple I'm
not I don't like I used to like complex
things and to do also like I like to
keep things very simple now and the
simplest thing I can think of was I had
one object going in something does the
work and then one object coming out
there's not like all these weird context
things where I can reach out to do other
stuff
nope just like everything that you need
to do the work must be passed in through
that request object and then everything
that you needed to worry about on the
other side is passed out through the
response object there's no other kind of
indirect inputs or outputs so we then
took this another step further so this
is just talking about the kind of the
main meat of the work and this this
middle handler we started to move
everything related to be able to handle
that request into that single that
single class that represented everything
to do so we had more or less complete
encapsulation of how that work needed to
be done so that when the request came in
I don't it was basically a black box I
don't know what the internals were doing
it would do all the work and then
finally out coming the other side was a
response and as much as possible we try
to push all the behavior inside of these
handlers so that I had one spot to go to
to understand what was all the logic
necessary to be able to fulfill those
requests so inner systems we had again
queries and commands modeling the
queries started with that initial
request object upfront now some of our
queries were very very simple that is it
was just a class to represent the
requests to get information and so these
classes may not have any data on them
whatsoever and you may look at it and
say well gosh shouldn't I kind of a
waste because it's just a type with no
information but that that class
represents a concept and that concept is
requesting information so in this case
this class represents the query for some
index page in this case maybe the index
page for people or invoices or orders
whatever that might be this represents
that distinct and unique request for
that data one thing you also notice here
is that I'm using inter classes to
basically scope this request object so
instead of me having like generic
reusable queries that it can be used to
all cross my system I tried to not read
use as much as possible and for for us
actually reuse was a four-letter word
even though it's five letters some spunk
spelling I guess he can jam thanks
together anyway we tried as much as
possible not to try to share logic
between different handlers to say let's
keep everything as distinct as possible
and using these inter types let us
really represent that concept that these
things really belong inside the scope of
this one single page so remember
Aquarius could get a little more
complicated so if we needed to have some
kind of parameterization going on with
their queries well then this these would
just be additional properties on top of
our query object so this is for example
represents viewing as some additional
details for I guess like a course or
something and so all the different
parameters that you might see in the
either the the URL or any kind of
parameters I'm pulling out of context
I'm just passing through as individual
properties and I try to capture all the
data that the query handler needs in
order to perform its work and put it in
this individual query object the idea is
that if I want to know how does this
query handler behave what information
does it need I again just have this one
single spot to go to to see what the
result is or to see what the inputs are
now of course my query does implement
this interface I request of T and so
this tells me what the response object
looks like as well so this query is the
request that returns this other model
class so those two things are always
going to be explicitly linked to each
other I will never have the case where a
query could potentially return multiple
response types each individual request
only returns and only represents being
able to get one kind of result and again
it's just this avoid reuse as much as
possible we can do one more even more
complicated things like paging and
sorting and filtering all the crazy
things you can do with with a
complicated search page these again were
all just properties I would put on my
query object and very often times I
could bind that query object directly to
the request parameters to make my life a
little bit easier
so now that I have my different query
objects my query requests modeled I now
turn my attention to the response
objects now the response objects don't
just live by themselves like none of my
systems I just take those responses and
just directly give them to the end user
as objects they have to go through some
sort of transformation so typically that
response object is passed to something
that then renders that information to
the screen somehow so for this example
let's just pretend like we're using
classic MVC style architecture and that
response is then going to be passed
directly to the view so the idea is that
that response object is artistically
crafted just for that one view and for
nobody else so I don't try to share
responses I make that view or whatever
page it is only use that one single
response object and whatever I need to
be able to render that screen I have to
have in that response so it's a one-stop
shop for all the data I could possibly
need to be able to perform whatever
thing I need to do to the final end user
in this case rendering HTML so some of
our responses or simple they just be
like here's some just dumb properties on
there and this is all the information
that I need to show on the screen now
you'll notice here that it's not
connected to any kind of like domain
object or entity framework thing or and
hibernate thing it's not connected any
RM the idea is that everything that's
necessary to be able to show that
information is then captured in this
object and I don't have to go back out
to anything else to be able to get data
everything that's that I need is in this
one single object but things could get
complicated I could have like
parent-child or like the parent
information and then detail information
and so for those kinds of things
I could have this concept of an inner
class again so if I needed to show
another list of information instead of
again me trying to share those classes
and types outside I explicitly modeled
those as inner types so that it
basically prevents us from trying to
share those objects outside of the scope
there may be other pages in which I show
similar information
but I want to guarantee that if I need
to change this screen I can change this
class and not care about about affecting
anybody else before when I had that
layered architecture we were very much
sharing different methods and classes
and types throughout our entire
application and so we kept having this
problem that I need to change some
method in my repository but that methods
being used in three places so I asked
myself well do I need to up do I need to
like break it out into its own method do
those other classes and other places
that's using it also need this new
change that I'm making with this I don't
have to care about anybody else really
this is like there's like The Selfish
Gene here or it says I can just build
whatever I need for my individual screen
and I don't care about anybody else this
is just what I need now in some cases we
would see the commands and queries sort
of linked together and you can think of
this in terms of viewing a form on a
screen so if I'm editing something or
creating something you initially have
that first request which is to show the
form well if something needs to actually
generate that HTML for the form and so
we'd have an initial query to be able to
show that form so we've had this kind of
duality in which a queries response type
would actually be the command and then
the command would eventually be
submitted back up through the form to
actually do the work so these things
would kind of be chained together I'd
have a query to build out the command
which was the form and then I'd submit
the form again to then sort of rehydrate
the command to actually perform the work
so you see this a lot in MVC
applications where you have and get in a
posts that are doing like the git is
returning a view model and then that
same view model is going back into the
post this is the same kind of thing here
where the queries response is the
commands that I bind to the screen and
then finally I think that same object
and push it back through in this request
the final request object here so with my
query inputs and outputs represented as
these requests and objects we then
turned our attention to the commands now
commands are going to be a little bit
different than the queries the typical
query
request don't have a lot of properties
on them but in our command requests I
need to have all the information
necessary to perform the action on those
request objects itself so our request
objects would include all the data
necessary to be able to perform that
action and most typically I could just
look on the form on the screen and say
ok I've got these input fields so just
take all these input fields and
represent them as first-class properties
I'm a command object and then rely on
whatever asp net core or whatever
server-side framework necessary to be
able to take those raw request variables
and then bind them to this object to be
able to be processed later on I wanted
to make sure though that whatever I
needed to do to be able to perform this
activity whatever information I needed
had to be represented on this class
itself oftentimes we saw that some of
our some of our kind of business logic
would do some work with it and reach out
somewhere else like oh I also need to
know who the current user is I need to
know like what time it is so we said no
none of that everything you need has to
be on this object so that we can we can
effectively reason about what the work
it's actually doing behind the scenes
this is a little this is kind of hard
for us because it's so easy just to be
like who's the current user but it was
difficult for us to reason about the
behavior without understanding that this
is all that's necessary to perform that
work on this individual object by the
way it starts to look very much like
messaging except this is in process I
will say if you're doing this this is
all synchronous in process don't just
take these and decide I'm just going to
throw them out into some kind of message
bus or on a cue you will have a very bad
time dot gif or gif because our
interactions are really meant to be
synchronous so you just can't take these
and say we'll just make everything
asynchronous and the application will
work just hunky-dory so looking at these
properties these come directly from a
form on the screen so each of those
properties I usually use to be able to
build out this HTML as well so I knew
that this had an enrollment date because
my form was or the HTML was built based
on that proper
existing and so when it finally gets
posted back up it's all bound back
together on the other side now so far I
know this leg this application is not
doing a whole lot it's just like
basically crud based operations I get it
I'm not that I'm not that creative with
sample applications I just steal from
others and so this is one of Microsoft's
example that didn't have a lot
complicated stuff so let's pretend that
we don't have just a simple crud
application and we have something that
is doing more complicated work and that
more complicated work instead of just
having these kind of very simple crud
based operations associated instead we'd
have individual operations represented
as tasks to do for the end user so this
one for example and as a mock-up of a
task based UI for a student so I can
view the student details but I also have
the ability to transfer that students to
a different course I can correct some
grading or it can adjust their schedule
to move some of their classes around now
each of these kinds of tasks and
operations are very distinct from each
other so I try to represent every single
unique thing you can do as individual
requests handlers and responses in my
system so when I move towards this of
vertical slice architecture it fits
really well with task based you eyes
because I represent each of those
individual requests as the tasks you
could do on the screen and every task as
an individual request and try to couple
those two things as much as possible
with each other so I have transferring a
student I've correcting a students and I
have the scheduling of the student and
each of those requests is going to be
distinct from each other each of those
responses is going to be distinct from
each other and naturally of course the
actual handling logic to do whatever
it's necessary to perform those
operations again I'm going to keep those
completely separate from each other as
well all right so we've talked about the
query requests query responses command
requests next up are the command
responses and this is probably the most
controversial part of this talk even
though I've never done before I'm gonna
assume it's controversial
because this is this this part is a part
that tends to fly against some of the
traditional object-oriented advice
people get so most advice I hear about
commands is that commands aren't
supposed to return anything which may be
the case for a lot of our commands that
I just have a some kind of requests to
go in and do something the handler does
there's to work and they don't have any
kind of response but for a lot of our
systems we can't just stop with nothing
I'm like okay did the thing but like
what was the what was the result of that
thing it did it did it succeed that it
failed am I supposed to just look for
exceptions so we started were so
representing the kind of result of the
operation as some kind of individual
result object so these days a lot of our
commands actually do return something to
tell the end user like and this was some
result of your operation so that we not
to make like another request to say okay
now what did you just do was that was
that successful or not the simplest
approach would be to just represent the
result of our operation as a simple
true/false success or fail so our
requests implement this I request of
bool and then I return the results as
like good or bad yes it succeeded or no
it did not
there could be some cases in which I
need to know like some more details
about what happened so let's say I'm
actually in this application creating
something like creating a student or
creating an order so I need to know some
information about what just happened
so in this case my response could be the
ID of the thing that's created so the
handler after it's done creating the
object will return back out the ID of
whatever was created so that I can
finally at the end say okay I've got the
ID then typically do some kind of
redirect to say okay and now here's the
thing you just created as opposed to
just redirecting to the list of things
and it's left to the end-user to figure
out wait which one was the one I just
created was it that one no you want to
be like okay here is the one that you
actually created and we can only do that
if we have the actual ID coming out the
other side
now we can get like way more complicated
than this if I need to have maybe more
complex response types and maybe I need
to know not just that it was success or
failed but like why did it succeed or
why did it fail so we started to build
more complex response objects we call
these command results
this command results represented either
a success or fail but when it failed I
had to know what was the reason why it
failed and I can show that reason back
to the end user it could have a more
complex payload so now I have not just a
response than just a true or false or
just a failure reason or a good now I
could put any kind of payload in there
so maybe it's maybe it's the flattened
out object maybe it's here's the here's
the main thing that you did and here's
all some other data as part of it now I
have the ability to return back outs
some more pertinent information to the
end user for what they just the
operation that just performs so some for
some of the more complex applications
they're doing more complicated work
behind the scenes for their commands
then I start to represent the results of
those commands as another kind of
first-class citizen in our application I
would say don't start with this it's
tempting to say let's just choose the
most complicated in solution because you
never know if we might need all this but
I tend to find it's easier just to start
with the simplest thing that could
possibly work and then know that this
thing exists so that you have a place to
refactor towards if things do get
complicated I also like to have this as
sort of a kind of a blanket response
across my entire system because it
annoys developers I'm like ah I just can
I just returned nothing like nobody
cares I don't need to no one's acting on
this result so I'd say only introduced
this in the cases where you actually
need to act on the result itself so once
I have the requests and the responses
for both commands and queries modeled in
my system now an a actually do some work
and this is like the thing I really want
to focus on which is handling these
requests and the work that I find inside
of them first up let's look at query
handlers
now again the whole idea behind this is
the work to be done for hailing a query
should be completely encapsulated inside
of that handler from the outside
perspective all I see is a request going
in some black box and some response
going out so have whatever tools
necessary or whatever means at my
disposal to be able to do whatever that
work is so it could be something as
simple as using auto map because like I
have to show this tool right like I'm
not almost required to at this point I'm
using my preferred mode of using out a
mapper which is to use linked
projections to be able to project
straight out from my domain model
directly out to a DTO if you're using
autumn a per and you don't know about
project two I would say please look it
up because if you get one thing out of
this talk it is if using on a mapper
please do this you will have the least
amount of problems and least amount of
headache if you just go this route and
what this is doing behind the scenes is
converting the configuration of how to
go from a source to a destination object
into a link select projection and ORM
know how to take that link select
projection projection and translate that
directly into sequel so this is
equivalent to a sequel view where I have
a predefined select statement to say
select this directly into this DTO so
with projections I completely skip any
kind of intermediate rich domain model
and they go straight from sequel duty to
DTO except with this method I don't have
any kind of handcrafted artisanal
bespoke sequel that I know we all love
to write right so with this model I go
straight from that sequel straight to my
object but we can still do sequel if you
want to like if we want to just drop
down to using raw sequel for whatever
reasons maybe we we want to show off
that we know how to do cross join their
correct way or we want to show people
how to use common table expressions like
you can still do a sequel as long if you
want to it's it's just fine I would say
if someone's forcing you to do store
procedures you could still do that I'm
sorry for you if you have to still do
that but from the
outside perspective I don't care what
you do I just do whatever you need to to
take that rest quest and then return
some kind of response so the handlers
are intended to encapsulate all that
sort of logic necessary to build a
response so it could be using EF core I
could be using dapper I could be using
HTTP client maybe have to call it to
some other web api to be able to get to
get that information maybe I have to go
out to some kind of composed crazy API
gateway to get information and maybe
have to take a bunch of different
sources together to put something
together that's maybe that's just some
kind of like meat grinder they're just
like churning a bunch of stuff together
and then outputting response but the
nice thing is from my applications for
perspective I don't care
all I see is a query then some kind of
black box that's going to handle the
query and then on the other side is my
response
it's also possible in one application to
have all these different kinds of query
handler approaches to my handlers I
would suggest being maybe not do the
meat-grinder approach like if you have
to do that maybe try to simplify that
but it's certainly possible that I could
use the correct tool for the job for
each individual handler which is
shocking I now use the correct tool for
the job now there are cases that we do
run into duplications so I could have
two different classes that have some
kind of common common query logic and
this is where I typically like pump the
brakes with mind if my teams to say you
know the first thing you should do
whenever you see duplicated logic is to
ask yourself is it just accidentally
duplicated that you just say it just
looks the same just coincidentally or is
it literally the same logic that needs
to change at the same time for the same
reasons forever and ever
so if we had that case that we just we
know that this should be common shared
logic then we pulled that common shared
logic into something what is that thing
whatever you want could be a class it
could be a function
extension method could be another
library I don't really care just used
use a little kind of standard
refactoring techniques to pull that kind
of common logic out queries are really
the boring part to be honest like it's
just like get the data out as quickly
and as efficiently as possible but
otherwise it's like it's queries it's
not that exciting
the interesting part I think comes into
the command handlers which is the really
work doing the real work happening in
our system so for our teams what I like
to do is just again it's the they don't
a lot of my developers want to start off
with the most complicated solution
possible but I really try to ground them
saying just just do the most boring
thing that could possibly work imagine
those old store procedures let's do the
most boring of procedural code as
possible
and if that's all you need to do then
just stop right there like if it's just
one or two lines of code and it works
then just stop that's okay
well a couple of things I do make sure
that they do as developers one I want to
make sure that we don't introduce any
unnecessary abstractions if that handler
needs to use something just use that
thing directly don't introduce some kind
of abstraction on top of it so in this
case I don't have any kind of like
repository on top of my DB context
I just use the DB context directly
because I know that this logic is
completely encapsulated from other
handlers then why do I need an
abstraction why kind of just use all
these things directly I don't need to
have that kind of indirection it's not
adding any value to my system so anytime
I saw any abstractions I would reject
the pull request it never actually
happened because we would tell them not
to do in the first place but we made
sure so just use all those things
directly and the only time I put in any
kind of abstraction is really for
testing purposes so if I'm building an
application has to talk to sa P boo then
I want to put something in front of me
between me and it's because s ap is
horrible to deal with and it always goes
down so only in those cases where I want
to isolate my system from others want to
introduce some kind of abstraction
otherwise just reuse the real things and
call it a day
I also find that the people that really
hate dependency injection
they really hate abstractions that get
enabled via dependency injection for me
if my handler is really small and stupid
my dependency injection configuration is
also really small and stupid so I don't
really have any problem with it just
like I have the requests going in if
that handler needs other things to do
its work then those other things need to
be passed in via dependency injection
and that's it now sometimes these
handlers can get really gnarly and ugly
and I tell my developers like just
because we're using this pattern doesn't
mean we have to determine we have to be
okay with ugly procedural code so just
don't panic remember that we can always
go back to the old TDD mode of red green
refactor although most people I know
just stop at red and green and like move
on to the X feature but that last step
is actually important we need to look at
the code that we just wrote scrutinized
and it say is there something we can do
it to make it more easy to maintain over
time so at this point I actually just
fall back to the kind of 20 to 30-year
old techniques to make this kind of code
better we look at the different code
smells I typically find there so for
these kind of handlers I usually find
that the class just got too big and so
the major code smells I'm looking at are
gonna be it's a large class and a long
method but there's a whole book written
about how to fix this kind of code
called refactoring which I highly
recommend the second edition is out next
year but it's JavaScript oriented so
we'll see and so there's just a standard
set of refactorings like and I can based
on the different code smells I see in a
handler decide how do I want to make
this code easier to maintain over time
typically I'm using the last one they're
composed method we just basically take a
really long method and break it up into
smaller methods all at the same
conceptual level I won't go into an
example of this because there would be a
whole talk by itself on refactoring but
just know like just use the standard
techniques of refactoring ugly code
inside handlers there's nothing that
says if you're using this technique you
have to keep the code as ugly as
possible I also tend to find behavioral
smells these are the kind of things that
it's not
like the structural code looks likely
but I also have some behavioral things
that are going on things like I've got a
lot of if-then statements I've got a lot
of complex conditionals going on I've
got duplicated code between different
things and so for that I actually use
another refactoring book I know patterns
right and that supposed to use design
patterns anymore but I still find that
they're useful in cases where I need to
put some higher level abstractions or
structures around the code I find on my
handlers there's not a whole lot of
patterns I use these days once I go to
this kind of approach I basically have
like decorator chain of responsibility
and strategy if I know those three
patterns that's like 99% of the pattern
needs I have and so really I just look
for the coat smells that indicate that
those patterns are may need to be
introduced it introduces to them when I
feel they're necessary what I really
want to drive towards though is trying
to push my behavior down so right now
everything is procedural inside that
handler what I like to do is start
pushing that behavior down into the
domain model so in this case my handler
now is just responsible for the kind of
data access logic this is a handler
that's doing a create or edit so the
logic inside of there is well do I am i
creating a new one or am i editing
existing one once I get that information
about which is which then I actually
delegate all the actual behavior down to
the domain model to do the real meat of
the work so now down there there's a
handle method and it says now I've done
the kind of data access junk now
delegate ought to the domain object to
do the real meat of the work so now the
domain has the real work to be done so
in this case the I couldn't fit it on
the screen because it was like 200 miles
long all this all this logic but the
general idea is that the real meat of
the work you can stop to push down into
your individual domain objects so now
instead of me having like these
repository abstractions to facilitate
unit testing now I do actually have
fully encapsulated domain models where
all my behavior is you notice as well
that I'm passing in my request objects
all the way towards my models as well my
domain models as well as opposed to
trying to break it out into something
else I don't in this case I don't care
if my
domain model knows about the commands
that need to act on the domain that's
really the only way I can really only
way I could do this kind of pattern
appropriately so ideally my domain green
box grows with behavior and that becomes
really where all the work happens in my
system now before I do any work
typically have to check to see can you
do that thing that you're trying to do
and so this comes into validation so
this kind of architecture I try to
Center my validation around the requests
and the handlers but a typically find
that there are a couple different
validation scopes that I have there's
the like just looking at the form itself
that request level validation and then
once I say like have you filled in all
the junk on the screen okay just let's
just make sure that maybe just a cat sat
on your keyboard but at least
everything's filled in I have that
request level validation and then I had
the sort of second level domain
validation which is things like make
sure that that email address isn't
already taken when you're registering
make sure that you can't ship a canceled
order make sure that you can't add items
to an order if it's already been
accepted that kind of validation can
only really happen inside the domain
model so I had this command level
validation that looks at not just a
domain model state but also looks at
maybe other domain objects maybe looks
at the database maybe has to go out to
somewhere else and inside of that is
where I have the kind of second level of
validation so my requests can validate
themselves in this case I'm using a tool
called fluent validation but you could
certainly use any kind of like Dana data
annotations is also a good fit for this
one the general idea though for this
kind of validation it can only look at
that request object for this request
validation it can't go out to something
else to see if it needs to be successful
not it can only look at itself so that
constrains what I can do in here but
that's okay I don't want to get too
complicated in my request validation I
want to keep it separate between
validating the request by itself versus
looking at other things in the outside
world to be able to say it is
this request possible to do the domain
validation is where I can start leaning
on those result objects so this one for
example I'm trying to approve an invoice
and it will look to see what the status
is and if the status isn't a good status
it will just return back a failure
reason saying I can't do this and this
is why so I've got my none that I've
validated the request I got my response
and the last little piece want to talk
about are some of the representations
that is taking that response and then
putting it into the outside world now in
the original NBC way of working of
things when I went down this path in
this architecture my applications wind
up looking something like this that as
that is I had a controller with
basically no behavior in it whatsoever
it was just just like taking the request
object and then delegating off to
mediator to actually do the actual
handling of the work but the controller
itself was almost pointless it was
basically just a description of routes
and then left on the right hand side you
can kind of see that I still have a
little bit of disorganization like the
controller contains stuff for everything
but then when I want to see with the
actual work being done it's then split
out to these other classes these days
though if I need to do server-side
rendering what I'll do is instead use
razor pages which fully encapsulate all
the work necessary to be able to handle
the requests in one single place so in
this case I've got a single razor page
that has the data to be shown on the
screen so that's that that data property
that has that model that has the request
and response objects it has any kind of
validation fit configuration handling
everything necessary to be able to
reason about this one request is in this
one single spot and then if you want to
see how the thing is actually rendered
then of course the the actual razor of
CS HTML page is right next to it so
everything's right next to each other
that means that when I'm money
developers are developing in a system
they're only ever adding files they're
almost never editing files an editing
file is an editing thing
is where we have merge conflicts and
potentially bugs creeping in because I'm
changing code as opposed to adding code
so ideally I'm only ever adding code and
by having everything encapsulated in one
single spot for new requests I can have
a reasonable guarantee that I'm not
breaking anything else
now Web API s are gonna be a little bit
different because very often I'm sharing
a lot of different actions for a thing
on one single single page application so
this one for example I've got different
actions to perform at an order I can
approve an order reject an order hold an
order or cancel an order each of those
has their own individual handlers
however if I'm looking at the browser
those are just buttons that aren't that
are on the screen but I don't I don't
leave that screen so what typically
happens is all those handlers actually
do return a common result object that is
then passed into my single page
application hopefully reacts or view and
hopefully not angular and then my life
is much better so that one single
response object is bound again to just
one single view on the screen so what
I'm trying to get to here is a one to
one with response objects and the
representations but sometimes of
representations are shared against lots
of different requests and that's okay so
with all this in place I still notice
that when I go from handler to handler
to handler I may have some duplicated
logic across a wide variety of different
handlers and so it's not enough for me
to just say we'll just extract all those
pieces out into one class and I have
anything call it I could have
duplication that just basically
stretches across all the different
handlers in my system so what I'd like
to do is to say for every time you call
this handler also do this other behavior
or this other logic and so for us we can
use the decorator pattern in order to
achieve this I don't like to call the
decorator it's kind of a weird name so I
called it pipeline behavior because some
frameworks call them pipelines some
calling behaviors so I just called it
both why not
so these pipeline behaviors wrap the
handler with additional logic and I can
then stack them as well I can have
additional pipeline behaviors all
wrapping my one single handler this is
all still transparent to people using
the handler they don't necessarily know
these other things are going on or don't
have to worry about them but allows me
to have cross-cutting concerns wrap
around by individual handlers so think
this is similar to action filters and
NBC wear filters wrap around the
execution of an action you can do
additional behaviors this is exactly
what I have as well I have a very simple
interface that takes in the request
object and then takes the next action to
perform as a parameter and I need to
return back out their response so let's
say I want to have every single handler
wrapped in a transaction I can do that
now with an additional behavior this
behavior takes in the original request
object it relies on the whatever ORM you
want to use in this case it's in any
framework and then inside of the logic
it's going to say begin the transaction
call the next action whatever that might
be it could be a handler it could be
another pipeline behavior commit the
transaction but if anything fails so
there's an exception or perhaps I get a
I get some kind of validation failure
then go ahead and roll back the
transaction so with this this pipeline
behavior in place I get to remove all
these Save Changes method calls and all
my handlers and say you know what that
is taken care of for you I could do
something like a unit of work let's say
I get something like domain events maybe
something that needs to happen at the
end of performing some logical operation
and so after I've done the work I need
to complete my unit of work and I can do
that pretty easily now with a pipe on
behavior what if things fail and I want
to retry them well now that's very easy
for me to do I can just have a simple
while loop that says try the action and
if it fails just try it again
and if it fails some in number of times
okay then go ahead and throw the
exception but if I have like excuse me
if I'm using Azure for example like the
Azure sequel always goes down so they
have a built in like a called over and
over again so we have a similar thing
here that maybe I maybe I have
concurrency problems or I have the
possibility of a lot of concurrency
collisions so I can just put in a retry
policy in one place it says if I get
that if I get some kind of concurrency
exception just try the thing again and
then hopefully the thing resolves itself
logging of course is like that's a
canonical thing they do with decorators
is log every single request that's super
simple now I have one single place that
I log every single request and respond
to my system in this case I have log
with a scope to say I'm starting this
request I'm gonna call to the handler I
do the work and then I'm what I'm done I
say okay this is what I called and then
this is the actual response on the other
side you may have to do something
different in you with the whole g-power
GPD are gdpr whatever i don't worry
about this kind of junk so every single
request in response then can be logged
in the system and if something fails for
whatever reason I have a record of that
that I've just enabled with this one
single spot in my system registration is
pretty easy for these sort of things I
in my head I think of them as the
Russian dolls or they mature yeah sure
the Russian dolls where they're they're
like there's the meat in the middle that
is my actual work and then on top of it
I start to layer the other interesting
behaviors of my system but from the
outside I don't need I don't know about
anything I just know I have a request
I'm sending in that request it wraps
everything in all those behaviors calls
a handler and then out the other side is
my response now the final one a part I
want to talk about is testing so looking
at all these different things going on I
have a different a few different scopes
of testing I want to look at but overall
I can look at this set of work being
done and see that basically this breaks
down into there's an arranged part
which is the request there's the act
which is the middle junk and then the
assert which is going to be looking at
the response so when I'm testing these
kind of systems I want to make sure that
as much as possible I'm modeling the
reality of how the system typically
behaves if I want to get confidence out
of my tests then they have to model as
much as possible how the real world and
how the real application actually works
so that means that when I set up my
tests it's gonna set up the application
very similarly to how my framework will
set things up but I'm not using that
testing extension from asp net core
because that's like sending raw HTTP
requests in that's like way too much for
me so instead what I'll be doing is
basically just setting up all the
dependencies and environments but I'll
still just be calling handlers
themselves now there are some stuff that
asp net core does for us and executes
everything inside scopes so i want to
mimic that kind of behavior my tests so
how these simple methods to say execute
something inside of a scope then
providing you a callback to say okay do
something with the scope that you're
working with so I've got a couple
methods here to say execute something
inside of a scope exactly like how every
single asp net core request works if I
need to set up data those will be also
done inside of some kind of scope so in
this case I'm passing in an action
against the DB context I will go ahead
and get the DB context outs perform
whatever actually need upon it and then
call Save Changes to make sure that all
your changes are saved I'll have a
helper method now to send requests down
to as well so this will rely on that
previous execute scope method to be able
to get out the mediator object just like
my razor page or controller was doing
calling cin to send the request down and
then that's all wrapped inside a scope
which means i have all the pipeline
behaviors and all the things that we're
executing in the normal request pipeline
of an asp net core application i'm going
to use a trick that I thought I'd never
use the C sharp five six way of doing
using static
so I'd say using static testing which is
all those test helper methods and now I
don't think whole like base fixture dot
send instead of just have a weights in
de sink and have a nice little helper
method be able send out requests and to
be able to get the response inside a
test my queries I basically set up the
data that it wants so you create a bunch
of objects say insert all those objects
then and my test I say send those
objects down get the response back outs
and then my assertion is just look at
the result object and make sure the
result is what I expect now that does
mean that inside my test I will have
multiple transactions and multiple
scopes that's okay that's how the real
system works if I want to perform
something in my application I'm
typically doing a series of actions and
operations so I don't want to do things
like wrap everything in a transaction
and roll back at the end because that
will have some false positives I want to
use as much as possible how the real
application actually works and behaves
so that means that I really want to set
up my system through the front door and
out through the back door so in this
case my setup is also sending a command
to do work that ensures that and runs
through all the validation so I can't
setup junk data it performs all the side
effects necessary and I know that this
is almost exactly like how an end user
would actually use the system but now
it's represented as these first cost
operations in my test I can't always do
that sometimes I need to set up the data
when necessary so just like it's just a
thing that happens in these kind of
systems that not everything I can do in
the system is available as an action to
perform through the user interface so
sometimes they do have to set up my own
data and then finally looking at
commands when I test those I will test
them with actual round trips so I'll say
do this work it will do that work inside
a scope transaction and when I come back
I say okay now go ahead and get that
information back out of the database and
check to make sure that all the things
were appropriately saved all the way
down to the database and back out again
and so I have to go all the way back out
so that's that find a sync to say go get
the thing pull back out and make sure it
matches that original command I had
before so that means with this approach
I wind up having
integration tests for every single
request to my system and for a lot of
times I can just go ahead and stop there
like if there if the handler is just
doing all the work right inside the
handler there's no need to unit test it
if I've pushed down that behavior into
my domain model that's where my unit
tests come into play i unit test those
things that are truly isolated and unit
tests and an integration test the things
that I don't actually want to isolate
and abstract so some key takeaways in
vertical slice architecture vertical
slices makes code super easy to add
change and delete because I had that
confidence to know that I'm changing one
isolated part of my system
and I'm not affecting anybody else do
not skip the refactor step a lot of
people hate this architecture because
they like my handlers are so ugly it's
because you didn't do that red green
refactor you just did red green or maybe
didn't have tests so it was just like
barfing in the keyboard and then was
done so don't forget that refactor step
it is still important and these kinds of
architectures try as much as possible to
push your behavior down into domain
model so that that complicated logic is
unit testable and you can't get that
quick feedback and then finally I would
recommend integration testing your
handlers and unit testing your domain
don't unit test your handlers there's
not really value in it you want to mimic
as much as possible how your real system
behaves is that that means integration
tests so that was vertical slice
architecture say yes to celery and no to
sticky onions if that means anything
anyone if you want to sample code behind
this it's on my github comm /j Bogart
there's some repositories with the
examples of this kind of code otherwise
thank you for your time and I hope you
have a great rest of the conference
thank you
[Applause]